When it comes to the blockbuster success of
the Marvel Cinematic Universe, there's a ton
of factors that have built the franchise into
what it is today.
But it was the 1998 release of Blade, a gory
action movie packed with leather coats and
thrilling set pieces, that first broke the
comic movie mold in the nineties and showed
longtime readers and mainstream audiences
alike that Marvel Comics could be cool.
But the 1998 release of Blade isn't the whole
story; in fact, there's a lot you might not
know about your favorite bloodsucker-busting
hero.
Here's the untold truth of Blade.
Tomb of Dracula
Blade was created by Gene Colan and Marv Wolfman
in 1973 during their run on the Tomb of Dracula
series, which followed a group of characters
tasked with killing the Lord of Vampires.
It wasn't just a horror comic, however; the
series brought Dracula directly into the Marvel
Universe with crossovers and superpowered
guest stars.
Readers eventually learned that Blade's real
name was Eric Brooks, and that he had received
both his strength and his hatred for vampires
from his mother, who was bitten by a vampire
while she was giving birth to him.
The event gave him immunity to vampirism,
as well as a prolonged lifespan and fangs.
After Tomb of Dracula's final issue, Blade
popped up now and again in the Marvel Universe
whenever a title needed a dose of horror.
Blade: The Movie
It was the release of Blade in 1998 that catapulted
the character to new creative heights.
The movie reinvigorated the concept of a vampire-like
vampire hunter, showcasing a character that
lived in the shadows, killing sleazy vampires
in outlandish action sequences.
Although the movie was directed by Steve Norrington,
producer and star Wesley Snipes deserves a
massive amount of credit for the character's
stature in pop culture history.
Snipes would constantly adjust shots and ad-lib
certain lines of dialogue or scenes that,
while costly, were always beneficial to the
final cut.
Snipes even ad-libbed one of the most famous
lines of the movie:
"Some motherf----ers always trying to iceskate
uphill."
Blade 2
Blade was a smash success with an incredible
idea for a planned sequel.
"And at the end of the film, Blade and Karen
pick themselves up and there are hundreds
and hundreds of vampires out in the streets,
and it's become planet of the vampires."
Norrington turned down the opportunity to
direct the sequel, leaving the chair open
for Guillermo del Toro to step in for Blade
II in 2002.
The film followed Blade as he was forced to
team up with a group of specially trained
vampires to hunt a powerful mutant aberration
of vampires called "Reapers."
The film turned out to be a success, but it's
arguably most notable for featuring a murderer's
row of character actors who would go on to
major acclaim, including Norman Reedus, Donnie
Yen, and Ron Perlman.
Critics were lukewarm, but the fans turned
out in force, turning Blade from a one-off
hit into a genuine franchise.
Blade: Trinity
Blade II had moved the franchise forward,
but Blade: Trinity went off the rails.
Directed by series writer David Goyer, it
intended to bring in more of the classic elements
from the comics, like vampire detective Hannibal
King and Dracula.
Unfortunately, by all accounts, it was a disaster
for everyone involved.
Patton Oswalt recalled his time on the set
with a series of stranger-than-fiction anecdotes
about Wesley Snipes.
"He would communicate with post-its that he
would give to the director.
And each one, he would sign 'Blade.'"
For his part, Snipes found the situation so
unpleasant that he filed a lawsuit against
Goyer, the producers, and New Line Cinema,
citing, among other things, the 'juvenile
level of humor' in the screenplay as well
as the increased focus on Blade's sidekicks.
Blade: Trinity ended up being the worst reviewed
movie of the trilogy, and put a stake through
the heart of the franchise.
But as with any good vampire, Blade wouldn't
stay dead for long.
[Intense music]
Blade TV
In 2006, Blade would return on the small screen
in Spike TV's Blade: The Series.
Snipes was replaced by rapper Kirk "Sticky
Fingaz" Jones for the show, which continued
the events of the movies.
While the show's expanding mythology seemed
intriguing, the series slowly hemorrhaged
viewers until the season finale — a slow
bleed that seemed oddly fitting for the vampire
show.
Blade in the Marvel Universe
While the Blade television show spelled the
end of the character's live action adaptations,
a new comic book was released less than a
week after the show's final episode aired.
The series combined Blade's original comic
book origin with his vastly more popular movie
personality.
This new version of Blade kneecapped Spider-Man,
owed Wolverine a blood debt for saving his
life from a vampire years ago, and occasionally
did odd jobs for S.H.I.E.L.D.
While the comic only lasted twelve issues,
it did have one of the oddest team-ups in
Marvel history.
Dr. Doom kidnapped Blade to assist him in
saving an innocent life from vampires.
The catch?
The victim was Dr. Doom's mother, a Romani
sorceress who was attacked by vampires decades
ago... but was saved by Blade going back in
time to save her.
Most importantly, the reasons Doom knew that
it was specifically Blade who saved his mother
was that he had perfect recall, even as a
fetus.
Gross.
Blade in Britain
Wesley Snipes' portrayal was so successful
that it's easy to forget Blade was born and
raised in London in the original comics.
After the cancellation of the rebooted Blade
comic, he appeared in the ensemble cast of
Captain Britain and MI13, which followed a
group of British superheroes battling magical
threats.
While on the team, Blade started a romantic
relationship with fellow team member Spitfire
— a vampire with superhuman speed who'd
been fighting her bloodlust since World War
II.
Having two vampires on the team turned out
to be a problem, though, when Dracula launched
an attack on Britain from his secret castle
on the moon.
Blade and the rest of MI13 were able to repel
Dracula's attack thanks to a captured Duke
of Hell, a mystical skull that kept vampires
from invading Great Britain, and the mystical
sword of Excalibur.
No one ever said this stuff was easy.
Blade the Avenger
While Blade is most well known for fighting
vampires, he's often found himself at odds
with a wide variety of immortal beasts and
demons.
In The Mighty Avengers, this involved secretly
rallying a team of heroes to fight the Deathwalkers,
four immortal rulers who each had dominion
over one of the elements.
Intriguingly, this required Blade to adopt
disguises so as not to alert the Deathwalkers
— first as Spider-Hero, the non copyright-infringing
spider-themed hero of New York, and then as
Ronin, a catch-all ninja costume for superheroes
who need to go incognito.
Don't worry, he eventually went back to his
trademark outfit.
Return to television?
While Blade might not currently have a comic
series, that doesn't mean Marvel's forgotten
about him.
In fact, there's a chance he might return
sooner than later — specifically, in an
upcoming season of the ABC series Marvel's
Agents of S.H.I.E.L.D.
A spokesperson for Marvel tweeted out about
the 2018 season with the hashtag #Blade, leading
fans to speculate that the show would incorporate
everyone's favorite vampire hunter.
Snipes even responded to tweets asking whether
he would be willing to reprise his role for
Marvel, saying
"When anyone asks 'Who could be the next Blade?'
you already know there's only one Blade fam!"
Ball's in Marvel's court…
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!